as we always do we look at things that
really make a difference to the way we
live the way we work the way we survive
the way we get better and we we found
obviously several things that did that
but this of all the things that the
judges looked at was the one we wanted
to award because it's so ubiquitous
every day every second of every day in
every year there are more than 50
cameras made with this technology and
it's amazing so here we are sitting in
the studio we're surrounded by this
technology we go to hospital we're
surrounded by the technology if we go to
let's say a laboratory we're surrounded
by tourists you know as astronomic
Observatory it's everywhere and it's
changing the way we behave and the way
we live and the key thing is the winner
of this prize have not only to be an
innovator they also have to have
benefited Humanity on the global
scarcity so benefit of humanity but also
on a sustainable basis so in reality
that means because it's engineering
invented something that has a commercial
life because that's the way to sustain
the innovation what's nice about this
price as well is the age range of the
prize recipients which shows that you
know one giant built on the shoulders of
another job this took a long time to get
what to where we are today now looking
at the oil and gas sector which you know
very well of course we had a agreement
to cut some cut production from OPEC
just before Christmas what are your
expectations for the oil and gas sector
this year so OPEX agreement was a very
important signal to the market that OPEC
was going to try and shed the world of
excess inventories which is is happening
which is good news which means that
things can become a bit more stable not
too volatile but it does demonstrate
that the price of oil is is not just
dependent on day to day supply and
demand it's dependent on geopolitical
activity whether it's OPEC or whether
it's crises in various parts of the
world so I think you can never forecast
the price of all what you can say is
it's unlikely to go but
though something and above something
else and I think unlikely to go below
the levels we saw the last time we had a
long time of weak oil prices and if it
adjusted to him today's money around 35
to $40 and very unlikely we're going to
experience the highs of $100 that
brought on so much supply that we had
excess inventories everywhere
someone you know very well Rex Tillerson
the former boss of ExxonMobil who is
about to become Secretary of State for
Donald Trump what's he gonna be like in
the job what's he what was he like as a
competitor my opposite number at Exxon
was his predecessor Lee Raymond and I
found him a very fine man I mean hecqs
on produce very good executives very
clear very well organized and real
executives I'm sure
Rex oh I know a bit overlap with me a
bit
were is just the same person what is so
good and of course is to see people from
different backgrounds coming into the
administration and I think that
diversity of background will be a
positive for decision-making now someone
else you know very well of course is
Vladimir Putin when you took BP into
Russia all those years ago and had
dealings with him then are you
encouraged at the prospect of a
rapprochement between the US and Russia
oh who wouldn't be it's very important I
think that we have you know great
relationships between powers great and
medium and small it's very important
indeed so the big question is on what
basis is there for approach mom and I
think it has to be surely on the basis
that mr. Reagan said any relationship
would be which is will trust but will
verify